now find the height of the point of
collision above a B find the height that
the point of collision above a B above
the horizontal where you gonna go you're
gonna take your wire equation either of
them right and just sub in T equals four
okay I think you guys can handle that
part of you so I'm gonna skip over to
the last part of the question find
correct to the nearest degree the obtuse
angle between the directions of motion
all the particles at the instant they
collide okay right now this is where the
fun really settles in what's the picture
these two particles are gonna collide in
some way say they might collide like
that okay there's my collision so I'm
looking for an angle now if they go off
like that one of the ways you can make
your angles obese just by drawing some
tangents is if I draw a tangent in there
this angle here that's the obtuse angle
that I'm after
okay the angle between them so how do I
get that
okay yep yep and then what I do that yep
okay let's pause for dinner yep yep okay
good so your first option is you can go
angle between two lines okay it's worth
noting by the way that the angle between
two lines it'll give you the acute angle
okay that's the way the ten defaults
okay so once you've got that you take
180 minus and there's your two say okay
there's option one I'm not going to go
toward that option here even though it's
perfectly valid the reason why is
because what you would need is the
equation of the path okay
sure enough you can get the equator the
partner showed you how to do that before
okay but I don't have them yet and I
don't need them either okay so just
follow that in the back of your mind
that number one okay use the equation of
path and then take the derivatives and
then use that to do angle between two
lines let me show you the second
solution which is just using all of the
equations that we've got here okay
so regular equations of motion okay now
I'm gonna have to do this twice this
whole process gonna do once for the
first particle and once for the second
product okay so
what I want you to do is set up all of
your equations your X and your Y for
each of the particles okay so your first
particle right particle one okay it's
horizontal position is given by 30 T
pause now on a second now angle there
was sine inverse of 4 for fit yes okay
so I actually know what this is already
that's 3/5 okay so this part is going to
be let's see Q 30 times 3/5 that's going
to be 18 t what's that right 30 times
3/5 yeah okay good so there's X 1 now
that what that lets me really easily
read off is my velocity for this first
particle right because velocity is just
the immediate e so I DX DT okay so
that's just like an 18 that okay all
right now if I want to know a gradient
I'm gonna need to know the other
velocities well the vertical one
so y1 was I think it was let's see minus
half GT squared plus but see here V 2
which is 40 and then we have T again
cause of business all right you're
thinking okay right now let's just
simplify this and then we'll
differentiate okay this is minus half GT
squared plus this is just 4/5 so that's
going to be divided by 5 gives you 8 x 4
gives you 32
yeah 32 T okay so now when I
differentiate Matt to get vertical
right this is going to become what's
this that's going to be just GT sorry
minus GT
and this will be 32 so far so good
okay now what I'm actually interested is
the point of collision like when T
equals four so this part here is
actually going to be I know aji is
that's ten so this will be minus 40 plus
32 that's the minus eight weights that I
got before sorry I change this this
should be 24
- 16 okay pause does that make sense is
that consistent it's heading upwards at
18 sorry horizontally at 18 so it's
heading in that direction
but actually it's been traveling so long
that it's gone up and then it's come
back down and they sent why this is -16
so this is the diagram that I'm gonna
draw for here it's going down like so
okay here's my X dot which is 18 and
here's my Y dot which is minus 16 okay
so far so good
alright now you're ready to repeat this
for particle two okay now let me save
you a bit of time because I've already
worked this out and it's the process is
exactly the same as what you go fit
through here the horizontal velocity for
the second particle is minus 32 and the
vertical one is minus 16 now does that
make sense
- 32 - heading to the left check - 16
it's also dropping down okay so what
I've got is this okay alright now come
back to this diagram here what was the
obtuse angle I was after it was this one
right so let me redraw this because this
is not accurate it's actually more like
this that's how they collide so I'm
interested in this angle here right now
come over to your rectangles which is
the angle that corresponds to that which
is the paramedical I put a vertical line
through it right you can see which
angles it's this angle let's call it
alpha okay
plus the same let's call it
okay sir the actual angle I'm after
let's have a look for our file that's
gonna be tan inverse of which sides in
what order opposite over adjacent right
absolutely different so that's 18 on 16
which is 9 or about 8 okay is alpha B
dot will be okay long as I was mid foot
okay feet up here
right opposite over adjacent so it's
gonna be 32 over 16 yeah that's two
right
so the actual angle of what is alpha
plus beta which is those two which I
think you're calculated what to tell you
use and they just get it to the nearest
okay so so I'll leave it up to you
whether you decide do you want to go in
question of path can use the dubious and
menus able to achieve lines or do you
want to just use these equations use
those three videos and then just add
them up with the rectangles I think
they're both kind of equivalent depends
on how the question gets set up for you
whether you already know an equation to
the part that would save your one time
but that's the way I approach that
question